[Music]
Disney has had more than a slew of
lovable shows some so incredible they
shouldn't have been canceled in the
first place
watch this video until the end to find
out the show that changed the way Disney
decided how and when to end their ever
popular series new around here
welcome to the things Channel give us a
like and hit the subscribe button below
for more great videos like this now on
to 10 cancelled Disney Channel shows
that should be brought back Lizzie
McGuire
Hilary Duff won our hearts over
instantly with her portrayal of the
lovable Lizzie McGuire accompanied by
her alter ego animated self this series
with a hit and went on to have a life of
its own even after being canceled Lizzie
Gordo and Miranda were the three best
friends we couldn't get enough of as
they tackle the ups and downs of
adolescent life they had us laughing and
crying the hit show ran from 2001 to
2004 and was met with disappointed fans
when it was over that only did it
kickstart Hilary Duff's success and
stardom the show also had a positive
message even when life is hard we can
persevere do you think Disney will bring
back our darling Lizzie even Stephens
from 2000 to 2003 we were swept away by
the Stevens family in sunny California
before becoming a major movie star Shia
LaBeouf played the lead of Lewis the
immature jokester the series followed
the misadventures of the Stevens family
a high school set comedy that was one of
Disney's first original series and it
sure did set the bar high the series was
full of gags and laughs and christy
carlson romano who played shia sister
always butting in to stop the fun
despite being canceled after 66 episodes
as for Disney's unofficial rule this
show will live on forever could a reboot
be possible in the future The Suite Life
of Zack and Cody
everyone misses these two cool dudes
running around causing havoc in the
hotel they call their homes zack & cody
played by the twins cole and dylan
sprouse made our childhood dreams a
reality of living the lavish life of
growing up in the Tipton hotel but what
happens when the stars of the show grow
up make a spin-off sure the suite life
on deck was a hit but it was nothing
like the original all grown up Cole
Sprouse has now moved on and that is to
play Jughead Jones in the CW show
Riverdale we miss the sweet life Disney
please hear our plea the proud family
BuzzFeed's 26 reasons the proud family
was awesome says it all that there are
that many reasons an animated series is
so impeccable means it should be brought
back the proud family centers around
penny proud a girl who navigates her
young years with the help of her friends
not only was she bold brave and funny
but she also dealt with real issues like
her struggle to understand her heritage
the show also had an insane amount of
guest stars such as Mariah Carey Shia
LaBeouf and Al Roker we haven't even
mentioned the dance scenes music and of
course the insanely unique characters
come on Disney that people want penny to
show us the way again Girl Meets World
from 2014 to 2017 this series took over
our hearts and our time the spinoff from
the ever-popular Boy Meets World was a
massive success the series follows Riley
played by Rowan Blanchard as she faces
life's lessons so why exactly was the
show canceled the show's rating
diminished hugely in its third season
forbes examined why this nostalgia show
didn't fare as well as the original
series saying while the series laid out
countless positive moral lessons it was
never quite as humorous as its
predecessor though many of the leads
reprised their roles in Girl Meets World
it seems many people must have missed
the original we're not sure why the
rating drops because we were definitely
there watching as faithful fans do
Hannah Montana good ol Miley Cyrus and
her real-life father Billy Ray Cyrus
star and this Coke sitcom The show
follows the life of a young pop star who
uses a disguise onstage to hide her
identity to even her closest friends the
show was nominated for four Primetime
Emmys and lasted for over a hundred
episodes Miley became synonymous with
her character Hannah Montana which could
have been the cause of her minor change
in personality for a hot second it seems
though our dreams of Hannah Montana
returning won't be coming true on the
Zach sang show when Miley was asked
about a reboot she said probably not as
it would mean she had to spend a lot of
time with her dad Phil of the future
when a time travel goes wrong and you
end up in 2004 from the super-advanced
year 21 21 and this sci-fi comedy series
phil has to manage just that the humor
comes from the struggle of trying
desperately
fit in imagine if you had to live in the
90s without cell phones and Instagram
that's how Phil must have felt the show
was originally titled the out of timers
but was later changed it was canceled
after only two seasons but was a major
success with a huge fan base we
definitely missed the show but we have
one bone to pick with Phil of the future
they said that chores would be abolished
by 2016 who why hasn't that happened yet
Kim Possible christy carlson romano who
he previously mentioned played wren in
even stevens voiced over the young
combatant kim in this animated series
kim lives a double life fighting off
villains while also dealing with social
dilemmas you know just a basic gal
trying to save the world the show ran
four seasons with action-packed fun and
always unpredictable Kim's best friend
Ron stoppable voiced by will Friedle
of Boy Meets World brought yet another
comedic level as the cartoon takes us
through Kim's crazy life it also taught
valuable lessons we wonder if we can
teach Disney a lesson and get them to
bring this show back Wizards of Waverly
Place
who doesn't love magic Wizards of
Waverly Place was a Disney fan favorite
and a show that we want back immediately
Harry Potter made its grand mark with
the portrayal of magical world but so
did our beloved Wizards Selena Gomez
David Henry and Jake Tian are now
household names thanks to the show the
three stars who plays siblings with
magical abilities each attempt to win
sole custody of the family powers Selena
brought endless fun and almost to Punk
spunk personality to the show the series
won two Primetime Emmys and won another
36 Awards talk about a huge success
someone give us a wand and we'll make
this show reappear That's So Raven
enough sad we've been wondering where
Raven went since 2007 Raven Baxter
played by the stunning and hilarious
Raven Symone brought the series to life
with her psychic visions of the near
future Disney's previous unofficial rule
of 65 episodes was hugely surpassed by
the show as it reached a whopping 100
episodes
his popularity suggests it did something
out of the ordinary the ABCB Club
explored why summing it up saying Raven
succeeded because it's one of Disney's
most
and durably funny shows the rare example
of a charismatic child actress actually
improving once she became a young woman
you go girl that's all for 10 cancel to
Disney Channel shows that should be
brought back what show do you miss the
most leave us a comment below thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]